ich habe etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zwei mal ein video ihr seht
mich immer wieder kurz davon hier damit
das video einen guten kontext ergibt
guten morgen es hat einfach geschneit
sich leute was geht ab und damit herz
willkommen wir sind heute den zweiten
tag hier in sofia in bulgarien die
hauptstadt von bulgarien und checken
hier mal ein bisschen was er ist es
wirklich so verrückt hier nicht habe
heute morgen extra meine haare nicht
gemacht weil wir jetzt erst mal zum
friseur laden also ich bin mal gespannt
was hier im presswerk kostet es wird auf
jeden fall glaube ich echt schieben wir
haben ja gestern schon einige
erfahrungen sammeln dürfen da kommen
auch glaube ich ganz coole videos lässt
man die kamera das ist übrigens lernen
wollen du kannst du nicht rauchen alles
wird ja ja ich war auf jeden fall letzte
woche in bulgarien in sofia und
deutschland wie einiges erlebt ich habe
sehr viel mit gefilmt und heute werdet
ihr einen weiteren einblick bekommen
kurz aspekten information bulgarien ist
das günstigste land europas und da habe
ich so ein paar sachen ausgecheckt in
diesem video geben wir zum beispiel zum
friseur gehen in den tattoo studio ich
habe so ein bisschen den tag gefilmt in
ein paar tagen geht es für mich dann
sogar noch in die schweiz weil das dass
das teuerste land europas und da habe
ich so einige sachen gefilmt wie man so
ein bisschen vergleichen kann das wird
glaube ich echt interessant das video
dazu kommt dann ja schnellstmöglich
leute wir haben jetzt hier direkt um die
ecke barbershop
auf jeden fall ist jetzt hier direkt um
die ecke barbershop eine rezension haben
die erst ja ja aber ich finde das sieht
eigentlich ganz cool hier die fotos
sonst bin ich mal ein und das ist so ein
typischer bulgarischer barbershop wenn
man das von denner und da gehe ich jetzt
mache ich mir jetzt mal an den haaren
bad machen ich zeige es euch mal kurz
das hier war der friseurladen der war um
die ecke von unserem hotel und der wird
uns empfohlen die hat wirklich ein
haarschnitt für männer 399 das ist
unfassbar günstig war erst ein bisschen
skeptisch ob das dann wirklich so
günstig ist weil das sind umgerechnet
zwei euro also ungefähr zwei euro und
eine rezension hat er sogar fünf sterne
hat das ding ja keine ahnung ein
bisschen komisch ich bin so lies wir
hatten ja in deutschland dieses jahr
noch gar kein schnee oder und hier liegt
einfach überall schnell meinte ich
wusste vor anrufen für termin meinte
nein dicker
56 leber das wären ich bin mal komme ich
einfach mal rein oder wo es zu
seht doch sogar open hier leute da oben
ist albin steiner an falsche nummer
ich bin okay dann warten wir mal also
leute wir sind gerade auf dem weg und
suchen noch einen anderen barbara stöckl
der hat ja irgendwie zu und der junge er
will sich hier sogar ein tattoo stechen
lassen
also vielleicht denke ich mir hier auch
mein erstes tattoo ja ich mache mir auch
mein erstes tattoo hier das wird eine
schöne er wenn ich das wirklich machen
das wäre zu heftig also damit habe ich
gar nicht gerechnet hier auf dieser
reise aber vielleicht mache ich sogar
echt weil ich wollte immer schon mal
eins haben
hey ein
hinterher katja vor anja pärson
ok
ok ja eigentlich ein
[Musik]
muss draußen weil alles gut weil wir
nach draußen
ich bin da auf jeden fall einfach mal
rein gesteckt weil ich fand es ganz
interessant leon der mit dabei war
durfte nicht sein dass wir auch komisch
in bulgarien du kannst alles machen da
ist alles auf und die leute tragen auch
fast nirgendwo was gut ist natürlich
nicht so optimal aber die frau die hat
sehr wert darauf gelegt nur ich durfte
rein also die hatte echt angst vor witz
und lehrern hat halt von draußen bisher
mitgefilmt
germany kann man ja
colonia cologne köln
köln früher hier vor
new york hat wollte ich da noch sagen
bei leber 99 alter krank aber das könnte
jetzt hingegeben also die hat einfach
losgelegt plötzlich zack zack zack und
hat mir irgendwas erzählt von fußball
ich habe mir leider nicht so viel
verstanden von fußballmannschaften und
ich hab schon gedacht das kann jetzt
nichts werden einen finden aber ich habe
auch versucht er zu erklären dass ich
gern übergang hätte aber das hat sich
nicht so richtig verstanden sie meinte
es geht nur ein millimeter oder 3 mm und
jetzt habe ich einen
tipp für bulgarien haircut also meine
haare sind jetzt wirklich sehr sehr
radikal geworden aber kein problem die
bucks yanar und wir suchen uns jetzt
noch ihr neues tattoo studio
warum
leute ja das war mein friseurbesuch wir
sind jetzt wieder zurück ich muss sagen
du kannst du noch einmal hin gefilmt ist
es nicht ganz so gut geworden aber sonst
ist es okay man also schon sehr kurz so
kurz wollte ich eigentlich nicht aber
trotzdem es hat wirklich also ich habe
14 länger gegeben das sind umgerechnet
ungefähr 56 euro hier ist die kürzung
zeige es euch mal ein rheinländer 99 mit
dem haircut also das ist schon wirklich
enorm günstig muss ich sagen kann mir
auch nicht vorstellen dass das in allen
bars shops oder ich glaube ich aber kein
problem er möchte jetzt nicht und da
schauen wir jetzt machen wir hier ein
cooles der schule finden also ohne
scheiß zurücklegen muss ich sagen der
hat war wirklich nicht gut das soll
überhaupt nicht böse klingen aber ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass diese
frau eine friseur ausbildung gemacht hat
oder so aber ich glaube aber shops
braucht man es war gar nicht keine
ahnung ihr könnt ja sehr gerne
kommentieren was ihr vor dem ergebnis
heute wir sind schon weiter gegangen und
lehrer möchte sich jetzt unbedingt ein
tattoo machen ist das aufstieg
[Musik]
also ich bin jetzt kein tattoo pro der
volt jetzt 40 euro haben für so ein
kleines tattoo ist das günstig wurde ist
das teuer sagen durch er hat natürlich
auch keine ahnung was so ungefähr ein
tattoo in bulgarien kostet aber 40 euro
für so ein kleines vettel das war
richtig unsere smile klagen erst mal
fehlen dann haben wir noch andere titel
studis abgecheckt im endeffekt sind wir
dann später aber doch wieder bei denen
gelandet wo wir als erstes waren und das
war wirklich echt cool da doch kurz als
infos zu weiteren baba shops wir haben
dort einige friseure slave to the shops
besucht und mal reingeschaut und wir
haben keinen weiteren barber shop
gefunden wo es so enorm günstig als ich
habe keinen plan warum das da so günstig
war die meisten nehmen so zehn bis
vierzehn laver also umgerechnet 57 euro
was natürlich trotzdem nicht viel ist
aber der war schon sehr sehr wild
günstig muss aber sagen heute gefällt
mir sofia besonders gut also hier kann
man es aushalten gerade mit dem schnee
und so eine richtig geile stadt egal ob
man hier ist es sieht alles cool aus
also ihr könnt ihr auf jeden fall mal
hinfahren wenn er mal urlaub machen
wollte bei uns ist das teuerste an der
software reise auf jeden fall der flug
zurück der kostet so viel wie alles dach
der kostet doppelt so viel wie alles
andere zusammen was wir hier erleben
leider ist wirklichkeit 560 euro für
zwei personen von software nach dortmund
zurück haben wir gezahlt also es ist
schon eine ansage dafür könnten wir noch
eine ganze woche ja wirklich
[Musik]
lass uns das mal so machen wenn er jetzt
noch teurer ist dann bezahle ich dir das
aber da musste es ins gesicht tätowieren
okay
das ist doch eine gute sache das sieht
gut aus also hier könnten wir termin
bekommen lernen für dein gesicht solche
wir sind jetzt endlich im irgendwie
tattoo studio und lehrern werden
tätowiert auf jeden fall länger
[Musik]
einfach machen einfach durchzieht
ich habe wirklich lange überlegt ob ich
mir jetzt auch ein bereits marco ich
habe ja noch keins aber ich muss das
nicht sein oder
[Musik]
bulgarien tattoo
von bist du zufrieden ja auf jeden fall
ja
wie teuer das war jetzt 80 lehrer also
eine petition
und deutschland hätte man das 460
gerichten ist auf jeden fall im
tattoo-studio wir hatten echt eine menge
spaß an dem tag und ihr könnt euch
selbst das video freuen wenn ich das
dann mal also ich hab da noch viel viel
mehr sachen getestet auch restaurants
und so wenn ich die preise von bulgarien
dann mal mit denen aus der schweiz
vergleiche das wird glaube ich echt
interessante leute wir haben gerade
minus fünf grad schon hier wir suchen
uns auf jeden fall jetzt noch was zu
essen ich würde sagen dass war es bis
hier hin checkt auf jeden fall mal so
viel ab bei denen ich wüsste wohin
fliegen sollte kann man auf jeden fall
machen also wir haben hier ganz viel
spaß und ja wir sehen uns als kommt noch
ein cooles video von hier könnt ihr euch
darauf freuen drei leute